i'm i have this feeling we're about oh
what is that
upset
[Music]
let's jump into the the matchups of
today we've got sardosha niko up first
to start off we know that uh sardoche
has been crushing it right the guy is
non-stop right now what are your
thoughts on how he's established himself
maybe as an early favorite and what's
gonna happen here today in his first
matchup with nico
he's really just doing chess all the
time and um
and it's it's going to be interesting to
see uh see how he fares because he's
probably the clear favorite at the
moment
there's one thing that i think nico
deserves a lot of credit for is she was
uh she was streaming chess before any of
the before this boom ever occurred
i remember i was actually playing grand
chess tour event in india in november of
and she was playing chess so it's it's
really great to see her competing in
pogchamps 3.
yeah i totally agree she was one of the
first people streaming chess before
before it was cool to stream chess right
and so it's pretty awesome and
who knew we would say that it's it's now
cool to stream chess
that's true yeah no i mean sarah dosh
has been just insane on
on the chest so uh it's great see now he
plays the h4 which i actually don't like
i really don't like h4 because now
there's like knight c6 and knight a5 and
i think i think nico's has a great
position so far
i agree she's she's developed developed
quickly and
with the king safe i'm with you that h4
while you'd love to i have an idea of an
h-file attack it doesn't quite line up
that sardocis put his pieces on the
queen side and going for h4
wow now he's playing e4 leaving his king
in the center
this is very explosive i mean black is
actually much better here i don't think
neo will play pawn takes pawn in knight
a5
but just just basically attacking the
center i mean this is very scary for
sardosh already this is uh
wow this is great great great start for
niko oh man
i'm so nervous already it's the first
game god i gotta calm down
i mean this is this is a great start
though this is a great start because i
mean i think everyone expects sort of
should be a favorite but i think a lot
of people are not expecting nico
to um i feel like she's actually
underrated relative to sarah dosh like
queen enough eight is another great move
here we're gonna have an end game and
sardosha is an extra pawn but at the
same time
when you look at the placement of the
ponds it's not so white's pawns are a
little bit
easier to target than blacks pawns are
so i think um
this is gonna be very interesting to see
what happens because i don't think
i don't think any of us expected nico to
um to uh to put up this kind of
resistance then she has a pretty good
position
i mean she is down a pawn but if down
upon an end game where there are no
clear ideas for either side you have to
maneuver
it's anyone's game yep especially when
she's the one up on the clock right and
i don't think sardosh expected her to
okay i mean he still has plenty of time
but but if
if this disparity stays and she's up two
minutes when we're under time pressure
that could decide the game
exactly yeah i know i mean this is this
is phenomenal this is uh
yeah this is just the start we wanted no
six moves no throbbings no no nothing
just just good
good clean shots
now look at that rook h2 he's he's uh
he allows the queen trade but with a
defensive move
i feel like he's he's not happy with
where this is going given that he was
all in on the idea of checkmate he can't
be thrilled about the endgame
great start solid chess almost 70 000
viewers already just on twitch alone
welcome everybody hog champs is back
um i i have this feeling we're about
oh why does that sing about the scene
ah oh man
well we have our we have our first
blunder um our first
one it's only it's only a night
but it's only a night it's not it's not
like a queen or anything so it doesn't
necessarily mean
that it's over like if sargeras just
takes upon an e6 and allows rook g1
but he castles which is very nice
yeah that was maybe the last chance the
blunder was to take and allow the skewer
but
he sees it and i and i think these kind
of moments here hikara are going to be
what separates sardosh if he does go on
to have a really good pog champs
tournament because i think he's put in
enough time that once he's better
i'm going to guess he's he's not maybe
once he's winning i'm gonna guess he's
not gonna blow too many games and
we'll see but but i think that maybe she
had her chance got a little impatient
with that night move
um but i expect sartosh to be able to to
clean it up from here
okay king defau king d5 try to run back
in okay
wait what is he doing okay i think
actually you know what sargeras is very
smart here i think he knows how to win
this without
worrying about what's on the other side
of the board
yep yeah okay he yeah i think he's
pointed to yeah he knows how he's just
gonna
uh and that's a that's a human
grandmaster thing to do right you just
go for what you know as a win and you
don't need to be
you don't need to play like the computer
go for what you know so that's again
just his experience showing
again yeah and yeah as long as he
finishes
yeah uh-oh okay okay and he sees it yeah
very nice by sardosh
well it'll be fun to see what opening
she plays given
the one lesson we had and i don't know
what else she's been working on but i i
hope she i hope she sticks with the
fried liver that was actually what we
worked on in caro
yeah well i guess we'll see um so so we
have sir right
and she plays f4 on move one wow
we worked on but it's okay all right
yeah so i would think here probably
i mean think where nico is you don't
really want to take the pawn but playing
a move like e4 here is good but i think
extremely difficult to find
um wow though
okay okay that's actually very funny
yeah she e4 is a great move and she
finds it
and probably the only real way yeah yeah
strike back here wow and now i mean i
think the problem is now now the rook on
86 is very good and the knight on d4 is
very good
yeah knight on d4 is good and it's also
attacking the bishop on d6
um the rook is attacking the bishop on
d6
oh oh no
oh she hung the bishop but she has a big
time advantage here she has a big time
um advantage g6 was a very nice move by
sarah dosh
but man he is like he is he is like all
over the place
it feels like pretty soon his entire
head's going to disappear
he's almost gone full thought yeah
okay so now will he see rook g2 here or
not oh he does
wow wow and bish does he find bishop oh
my gosh
yes yeah very nice yup
[Music]
let's go let's go baby
well let's let's let's wait let's see if
he can blunder here because again he
only has one pawn on the board
that's true a knight bishop mate oh
knight takes h1 oh my gosh he just blend
oh my gosh he is
he's not gonna lose this game but i
don't think he can i mean
uh yeah he's still gonna it's still
probably gonna be a draw he's gonna win
the match i think but oh that's uh
not what you're not not what you were
hoping for i don't know how you do that
i feel like you have a sixth sense with
the pogchamps commentary like you knew
the blunder was coming
and uh i i thought i thought he was
about to show that he was gonna convert
it but there you go
i mean he is still winning here with
correct play but i it's just like
a king d4
yeah if she runs her king to the corner
to go after the pawn on h2 she's she's
gonna
draw this game i think
[Music]
i agree
agree with him oh man
yeah that is maybe the largest bottle of
dasani i've ever seen in my life by the
way
that he just grabbed um all right
nico finds knight d2 you called it
hikaru she's good with the knights and i
think she's going to hold
yeah yeah so i mean sardosh is going to
win the match but i i think
either either like sardosh is like
overrated or nico is um
nico is underrated that was very very
good very very good
nico start start with you i know it
maybe didn't end the way you
you wanted it to but playing one of the
stronger players you
those games were extremely good in fact
you were better in both of those games
to start
how did you feel about about how you
played and came out here today
i was a little upset because sardoshe is
already so
good so i was like i get the hardest
player first
but i also heard i think the biggest
thing i was intimidated about was that i
heard that he does really weird openings
and really weird like
things and then i definitely saw that um
while we were playing i was like what is
he doing like he hasn't castled
the whole game like what is going on
i know nothing about your opening it was
the first time i played against it
even though i played a lot of games
recently but
well it was surprising or what you were
you were doing in early and
i was so scared and stressed i was like
i was supposed to win
if you look at waiting but i was
definitely in struggle and
well well paid for that honestly
i'm glad i was a good opponent against
you at least it wasn't too easy for you
so so sardoz you've been putting in a
lot of hours in the chest i think you
did a 20 to 23 hour stream yesterday of
only playing chess
um yeah i started like two weeks ago and
i i've been only playing chess for like
two weeks yeah
i just obsessed yeah no i i think it's
fantastic i think certainly you're one
of the favorites um and
actually nico i was looking at some of
the statistics and you've played a lot
of blitz games much more so than these
10-minute games with like five minutes i
think
um and i was wondering if that played a
role in terms of why you were moving so
quickly because in both games you had a
lot of time on your clock
um as as you were in the middle part of
the game and whether that was like just
duty or familiarity with playing quicker
shots
i just have a thing where it's it's
really satisfying when i could think
quicker and like i feel like it also
makes my opponent nervous when they're
i'm moving
too fast honestly when you were when you
were doing good moves in like tempo
like playing instantly i was like oh oh
the [__] is she
playing so well so fast so it was
registering me and
i i think i i blundered a lot because of
that i was being like
she's she isn't 800 that's not possible
oh thank you well congratulations to you
both uh for
just being here we got we got a long
event ahead here two weeks sardoche
you're moving on there with the win and
nico you played super well i'm i'm i'm
sure that
a lot of these other matches uh will
have a good chance to go your way so
thank you both for joining us and uh
best of luck in your next round
you